how much can Landing in snow protect you
from afall
well we've seen it save people who
jumped off a roof
or dived off a cliff
and yes even who fell from the top of a
mountain
but what about a fall from even higher
up
like from an airplane
how much snow would be required to break
that kind of fall
what kind of snow would be the best to
fall into
and how should you position your body
for a safe landing
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell from an airplane into
snow
okay whatevers if you're planning on
jumping out of an airplane without a
parachute you might want to check out
our video on what happens if you die
because that's what you'd have to look
forward to
the math changes depending on how much
you weigh but let's imagine that you
weigh 65 kilograms as you fall from an
airplane that's thousands of meters in
the air your body would travel at a
velocity of 55 meters per second and
when you smash into the solid ground
below that velocity would instantly drop
to zero meters per second causing
catastrophic injuries
but if there was a whole bunch of snow
on top of that Solid Ground
might be enough to save you from dying
don't believe me well it's happened
before
in 1972 a Serbian flight attendant named
vesnavulovich survived the mid-air
explosion of a jetliner after plummeting
hundreds of meters through some trees
and landing on a snowy hill
yeah she broke her legs pelvis some
vertebrae and fractured her skull but if
a little snow could save her life then
why not yours
but let's not get too confident here
because there are still a ton of ways
that this could go completely wrong if
you're going to survive you'll need a
bunch of factors to line up perfectly
the key to surviving a fall from an
airplane is to make your deceleration
last as long as possible okay math again
if you weigh 65 kilograms and fall six
kilometers you'd be heading down to
Earth At a velocity of 55 meters per
second if you land on Solid ground and
you only decelerate for half a second
you'll hit with a force of 7.1
kilonewtons
if you're not a math teacher or a
scientist that's 726 kilograms but if
you were able to stretch that
deceleration out by even the smallest of
amounts it could make a world of
difference
for example even stretching the
deceleration time out to one second
would reduce the force to 356 kilograms
and if you decelerate for two seconds it
would be 183 kilograms
Landing in a nice bed of snow could
definitely help you slow down enough to
save you
but it would have to be the right type
of snow
the snow would need to be able to
compress slowing your fall to less than
98 meters per second squared
so the snow must be thick enough for
this to occur about 80 meters
the reason why you need to travel at
less than 98 meters per second squared
is that this is 10 times the force of
gravity
the approximate acceleration that humans
can make without too much damage
so considering all this you'd better
cross your fingers that you'll be
landing in lots of soft fresh snow
because of its lower density fresh dry
snow can be compressed more and soften
your Landing pack snow and wet snow are
denser than fresh and dry snow so they
can't be compacted as much and wouldn't
extend your deceleration enough to save
you
but even if you're 100 sure that the
snow you're Landing in is fresh deep and
dry you're still not out of the danger
zone
to give yourself the best chance at
survival you're going to want to land in
a belly flop that may seem strange but
it would actually be the safest choice
you see if you land feet first all of
your weight will press down on that
small area but if you land on your belly
your weight will be more evenly
distributed so you won't be hurt as
badly now if by some chance you happen
to survive the landing without too many
injuries you're going to have to dig
your way out of the snow as you can
imagine falling all the way down from an
airplane would be pretty disorienting so
your first step for getting out of the
snow would be to figure out which way is
up one helpful trick that I always use
is to drool a little and see which
direction it slides down your face
the opposite of that is upwards
of course this is all easier said than
done in reality there's a reason we've
only heard of one person who's ever
survived falling out of a plane
because it's very unlikely to happen
about to get a little chilly in here
what's the coldest you've ever been
actually
foreign
well today we're cranking that down a
notch today you're heading into absolute
zero territory
is absolute zero really colder than
outer space
what could we do with such a low
temperature
and how badly is this going to hurt
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you touched absolute zero
so besides sounding like an awesome band
name absolute zero is the lowest
possible temperature in the universe
at minus
273.15 degrees it literally can't get
any colder
it's so cold at Absolute Zero that the
very atoms have stopped moving
that's really cold even the freezing
vacuum of space is only minus
270.41 degrees
so absolute zero is colder than the dark
reaches of outer space
and today you get to be our guinea pig
and touch something cooled down to
absolute zero I know right what an
amazing opportunity
now let's say we froze a small piece of
metal down to absolute zero temperature
would you mind picking that up for us
as you pick up the piece of metal you'll
find that it's absorbing all the heat
from your hand
your hand is covered in moisture which
is being robbed of all its heat
and it begins to freeze once the
temperature drops below zero okay you
can let go of the metal now oh you can
well that's because the water freezes
inside the tiny pores of your hand
and the surface irregularities of the
object so you'll get stuck
think of it like when you lick a
flagpole in winter
but a lot more painful and if you try to
remove the piece of metal the Flesh of
your hand will rip off with it
no Kelly Clarkson just remember you
volunteered for this
next blood vessels near your skin will
begin to constrict
this will reduce the blood flow to the
affected areas and help keep your vital
organs alive
it's like your body puts up a roadblock
the problem is this lack of blood supply
and oxygen to your skin can cause damage
to your cells
at Absolute Zero the piece of metal will
lower your cell's temperature until they
are so cold that the liquid inside them
freezes
this would create sharp ice crystals and
damage the structure of your skin cells
and brace yourself it gets worse
you can expect even more damage to the
lower layer of your skin aka the dermis
not to mention all the damage to your
hands muscles and tendons
okay uh maybe we should call it quits on
this
well because you were such a go-getter
you decided to hold on
hold on metal as long as you could and
as a result you've got fourth degree
cryogenic burns on your hand
this will eventually lead to gangrene
and extensive necrosis
do not Google that trust me
with your injuries there's only one way
to save you
amputation
so besides maiming you what could we
actually do with absolute zero
well hopefully the study of absolute
zero temperature will lead to
discoveries in cryogenic research
the field of cryonics seeks to preserve
whole human bodies at ultra low
temperatures around minus 196 degrees
yeah that's not as cold as absolute zero
but if we can get a handle on how to
work with such a low temperature we can
use this knowledge to prevent your body
from crystallizing and your vital organs
from being destroyed after you're Frozen
absolute zero is the lowest possible
temperature in the universe
nothing gets colder than that
so if the entire Earth suddenly cool
down to the most frigid temperature for
even five seconds it would wreak a lot
of havoc
just how cold is absolute zero
what would happen to your body at this
temperature
and
and what's the coolest thing about it
this is what
here's what would happen if the Earth
dropped to absolute zero for five
seconds
temperature is how we measure kinetic
energy of the particles in any object
yeah it tells us how fast atoms
molecules and particles move
the hotter a gas liquid or solid gets
the faster the particles move and when
that movement slows down the colder that
substance becomes at the lowest
temperature possible or absolute zero
particles stop moving altogether
this is because at zero Kelvin or minus
273.15 degrees Celsius no heat energy
Remains the coldest ground temperature
ever on earth
184 Kelvin or minus 89.2 degrees Celsius
was recorded in Antarctica in 1983 but
it doesn't even come close to absolute
zero
even the coldest known place in the
entire universe the boomerang nebula 5
000 light years away from Earth is just
a tad warmer at one Kelvin
so are you ready for the coldest five
seconds ever
[Music]
at room temperature you know that
comfortable range of temperatures of
about 293 Kelvin the air molecules move
at an average speed of 1800 kilometers
per hour
as the temperatures on Earth suddenly
plummeted all those particles would slow
down
at
0.00001 Kelvin the atomic particles
would be moving at a speed of about
0.18 kilometers per hour
that's 1 000 times slower than their
speed at room temperature
getting this close to absolute zero All
chemical reactions would be closer and
closer to coming to a complete stop
and this would be very bad news for you
and everything else on Earth
chemical reactions are responsible for
everything including how your brain
communicates with your body
without the trillions of chemical
reactions going on inside of you you
wouldn't be able to breathe or turn food
into fuel
temperatures near absolute zero would be
devastatingly cold even at a
comparatively toasty 77 Kelvin you'd be
in serious trouble
that's the temperature of liquid
nitrogen
after just a few seconds of exposure to
this temperature you'd suffer severe
burns blistering and Frostbite needing a
tow or 10 amputated could be a definite
possibility
so just five seconds of absolute zero
could do incredible amounts of damage to
all life forms on Earth
but I have good news
the chemical reactions wouldn't come to
a total standstill even at the near
absolute zero temperature of the
boomerang nebula chemical reactions do
still appear to take place
this is thanks to the strange effects of
quantum physics
and whenever quantum physics is involved
things get weird
with all the atoms on Earth at a near
standstill you'd find them starting to
Clump together they'd be forming a state
of matter known as a Bose Einstein
condensate
this would mean that every atom is in
the same energy State and essentially
identical to one another from a physical
point of view
they'd start to behave as a single atom
and if you could become a Bose Einstein
condensate it would be pretty cool
pardon the pun
for those brief five seconds you'd have
some unique physical properties like
superfluidity
yeah you'd be able to flow through tiny
cracks without any friction only there
wouldn't be any cracks because you
wouldn't be the only super fluid thing
on the planet
but there is a catch
Bose Einstein condensates can only be
formed when bosons are cooled to near
absolute zero
bosons are all atoms with an even number
of electrons
that means only some of the atoms in
your body and the environment around you
could become a Bose Einstein condensate
and lucky for you reaching a temperature
of absolute zero wouldn't be possible
if Earth and everything on it plummeted
to absolute zero it would instantly pull
the heat from the space around it
to keep you and the planet at zero
degrees Kelvin even for five seconds
you'd need an infinite amount of
resources
this makes it mathematically impossible
but that wouldn't mean that five seconds
of near absolute zero temperatures
wouldn't destroy just about everything
and nothing would ever come back
together from this soup of atoms that
you and the entire planet would turn
into
[Music]
Earth has gone through at least five
major ice ages in its history and you
better start adapting now because
another Ice Age is about to begin
hypothetically
how would a new Ice Age change Earth as
we know it
what could you do to survive on a frozen
planet
and how are we already delaying another
Ice Age
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we entered a new Ice Age
during all ice ages in Earth's history
global temperatures dropped well below
freezing across the planet and it wasn't
just a few icy trips around the sun
earth can take hundreds of millions of
years to thaw out
the most recent Ice Age started the
quaternary period around 2.6 million
years ago and technically we're still in
it today
ice ages have the power to radically
change our planet
they reshape Landscapes they create new
lakes and rivers plants and animals
cling to life either adapting or facing
extinction
so if a new Ice Age began today how soon
would our civilization collapse into
Chile chaos
our sixth major ice age would be a few
thousand years in the making and it
would begin with Earth's Tilt on its
axis going through its cycle of changes
an unstable tilt plus a little wobble in
our orbit around the Sun and there would
be less and less solar radiation
reaching the planet
you'd see the first effects of this on
the Northern Hemisphere
each year the once lovely summer
temperatures would start to drop
eventually they'd fail to rise above
freezing and that's when the snowfall
would begin to build up
over time that snow would compress into
ice sheets
these glaciers would start in places
like the northernmost regions of Canada
Scandinavia and Russia and they would
spread from there
the ice would mostly form on dry land
that's because the water surrounding the
ice would create a barrier preventing it
from expanding as easily
today about 10 percent of Earth's land
surface is covered by Ice
as our new Ice Age progresses you could
see that go up to about 25 percent
ice would cover Eurasia from the British
Isles to Siberia Himalayan ice sheets
would expand through Asia and while the
southern hemisphere wouldn't be as icy
an ice sheet would run from the southern
tip of Patagonia well into the Andes
Mountains
but ice wouldn't be the only change
heat levels could drop around 120 meters
lower than they are right now
this could close off the Mediterranean
Sea to the Atlantic Ocean
without anywhere else to go rainfall and
glacial melting would feed bodies of
water in regions that aren't frozen over
some Rivers would also change their
usual runoffs and form new Lakes
with all these changes and sea levels
around the world land bridges would
re-emerge Russia would now be connected
to Alaska and the islands of Indonesia
would connect to Mainland Southeast Asia
the borders would change and bring many
countries closer together
or it would result in whole new
countries being formed opening up new
land for you to migrate to
and you'd need to
regions that you and hundreds of
millions of other people used to call
home would be essentially uninhabitable
surviving the cold would mean moving
away from the iciest parts of North
America and Eurasia but the rest of the
world wouldn't be too welcoming either
it would get really dry
deserts and Tundras would expand so the
remaining tropical forests near the
equator would be refuge for much of the
planet's plant and animal life
but what about us
well during the most recent Ice Age we
actually developed as a species the land
bridges allowed us to spread out across
the globe and the climate forced us to
adapt with new tools and clothing
and as Earth re-warmed we started
farming
it's likely that we wouldn't fare as
well with a new Ice Age
not right away at least
almost all of our agricultural land
would be lost so intense overcrowding in
hospitable regions would create chaos
and unrest
you should get ready for extreme
competition for life's basic necessities
but I do have good news to ease your
worries about this frigid doomsday
scenario come on bring It
well sort of
based on current climate science and the
amount of carbon dioxide in our
atmosphere we may have postponed the
next possible Ice Age by about half a
million years
and if we keep pumping out greenhouse
gases
it's possible that we've not only
postponed it but we've made it
impossible
that just means we'll all overheat which
I guess is better than being frozen
[Music]
how much water would you need to
extinguish the Sun
how would we deliver such an enormous
amount of water anyway
and would all that water even make it to
the star wouldn't it evaporate before
reaching the sun's burning flares
whatever your plan is be careful because
trying to put out the sun would only
make it hotter
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we extinguished the Sun
before we dive into how things would go
terribly wrong let's talk about where we
could hypothetically find all that water
I've got some ideas
how about the universe's largest ice
cube
a gigantic space fire hose
or an entire Water World tossed into the
sun
okay fine let's be a little more
realistic no giant ice cube will be
passing our solar system anytime soon
that leaves us with one possible
scenario we'd have to sacrifice every
single drop of water we have here on
Earth
we would drain our oceans and deplete
all the fresh water too
then we'd build a very large fire hose
and blast it at light speed towards the
sun's core and then
wait did I say there was just one option
I forgot about the possibility of using
a water world
leaving the Earth with no sun and no
water seems a bit unreasonable
and we could avoid that ocean draining
scenario if we found a way to throw an
exoplanet into the sun
but not just any exoplanet we'd be
aiming for a real-life Water World and
we just happen to know where to find it
some 40 light years from Earth there's a
planet primarily made of water with an
atmosphere of steam
scientists named it gj1214b
but we'll call it the Water World
this planet is 2.7 times bigger than the
Earth in diameter and it weighs seven
times more than our planet
and it has much less rock and a lot more
water than the earth does
there would probably be enough water on
the Water World to put out the Sun
forever
but it wouldn't happen the way you might
expect it to
if we were able to crash that water
world into the Sun the first problem
would be the water freezing in space
same thing would happen if we could pull
out a gigantic fire hose with all of the
Earth's water and aim it at our star
the ice would continue shooting towards
the Sun but it would face Mass
evaporation as soon as it hit the star's
atmosphere
the water vapor would then break down to
its basic ingredients oxygen and
hydrogen and that's when something
interesting would happen
the sun may seem like a huge Fireball
but it's not exactly on fire inside its
blazing core the pressure is 340 billion
times more than it is on Earth's surface
this immense pressure fuses hydrogen
atoms together making helium and giving
off energy in the process
since hydrogen acts like a fuel for our
sun pouring water on it would be like
throwing gasoline on a fire
you'd see the sun turn bluish white as
it grew six times bigger
it would create an extreme heat wave
across our planet but at least we
wouldn't be engulfed by the expanding
Sun although there could be other
consequences
we wouldn't be able to put out the sun
with its own fuel but if we fired enough
water at it at the speed of light it
could break up the Sun the pressure
inside it would drop the hydrogen
couldn't fuse together into helium and
that would shut the sun down
but with no sun to give us warmth and
light the Earth would turn into a frozen
world
after just one year Earth's temperature
would drop below -73 degrees
most of the plants and animals would be
dead long before that
and what about us humans
well in the deepest parts of the oceans
geothermal vents could have kept us warm
and supplied us with energy but we just
poured all of Earth's water into the sun
dooming ourselves to freeze
lucky for us the only thing in the
universe that can do any substantial
harm to the sun is the sun itself and
that would take billions of years to
happen
[Music]
what if the sun disappeared right now
would you be able to handle Eternal
Darkness cold temperatures how about
flying off into space
the sun is the only star in our solar
system and it gives life to everything
here on Earth would we even be alive if
it vanished
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the sun disappeared the truth
is we wouldn't even notice for the first
eight and a half minutes this is how
long it takes sunlight to travel to our
planet so even if the sun disappeared
its last ray of light would take 510
seconds to reach your skin and what
about gravity the sun is the dominant
gravitational force in our solar system
it has all eight planets moving around
it so if the sun disappeared would we
fly off into space yes but not right
away the force of gravity turns out to
have speed too it is theory of general
relativity Einstein proved that gravity
is just as fast as light and not
instantaneous as was previously thought
this means the Earth would still be
orbiting a recently vanished star with
no clue of the upcoming Darkness
adjust for eight and a half minutes when
the last of the sun's Rays reach the
Earth Eternal Night wouldn't be our only
problem the very same moment the sun
disappeared from the sky Earth would
start traveling into space at 18 miles
per second assuming the Earth didn't
collide with any other planets or
asteroids or get sucked into a black
hole it would be moving in a straight
line for 43 000 years before it found
another star to orbit but you wouldn't
have to worry about that within two
seconds the moon would go dark since
there would be no sunlight to reflect
but the Stars would still shine and your
electricity would still work unless it's
powered by solar panels however gravity
and illumination aren't the only things
we rely on the Sun for plants need the
Sun for photosynthesis turning light
into energy is how plants stay alive
without sunlight most small plants would
be dead within days larger ones like
trees would survive for several decades
due to their slow metabolism this would
knock out the bottom tier of the food
chain most animals would die off slowly
only scavengers feeding on the dead
would remain until they froze to death
because within a week the average
temperature on Earth would drop to a
bone-chilling 32 degrees Fahrenheit and
by the end of the first year minus 150
degrees would be the new norm and it
would keep dropping until stabilizing at
minus 400 degrees Fahrenheit the oceans
would grow colder too but just on the
surface thanks to geothermal vents they
would remain liquid underneath despite
being buried under a thick layer of ice
so if you're lucky enough to survive
consider moving to the ocean floor in
the end the organisms living around
those geothermal vents would be the only
living beings not to notice any
difference they don't need the sun to
live and could continue to thrive for
billions of years until the planet
became a frozen chunk of rock drifting
in space
foreign
foreign have you ever met someone who
always feels cold even when everyone
else is warm we tend to joke that these
people are cold-blooded but do we even
know what that means having cold blood
involves more than just needing a few
more blankets than everyone else if we
all suddenly became cold-blooded instead
of warm our lives would be completely
different
why would we need to eat less food
could we only survive in warm climates
and how might our Cold Blood help with
space exploration this is what if and
here's what would happen if humans
became cold-blooded
when our body temperatures get too hot
or too cold we have built-in processes
like shivering and sweating to help
regulate them but cold-blooded or
ectothermic creatures don't have that
same luxury that means that if we became
cold-blooded our lives would be a lot
more limited and in the winter a good
heater could be the difference between
life or death do you think we'd be able
to survive if you were to wake up
tomorrow with cold blood there'll be a
lot of new things to get used to some
good and some bad
for one thing your grocery bill would be
a lot smaller as you wouldn't have to
eat nearly as much as you do now
warm-blooded animals eat a lot because
they need all that energy to keep their
bodies at the right temperature
but what if you like your three meals a
day sure you could keep eating as much
as you like but with no use for all
those calories all that food would go
straight to fat
if you're smart about it you probably
wouldn't have to worry about visiting
the doctor as much anymore either our
warm-blooded bodies provide a nice
constant temperature for germs to breed
in as opposed to the variable
temperatures of the cold-blooded
if bacteria and viruses can't get used
to your body's climate then your chances
of getting sick drop significantly but
that's not to say that you'd be
Invincible if you don't make a conscious
effort to keep yourself warm your low
body temperature could slow down your
immune system allowing bacteria and
viruses to creep up and infect you so
you may have become a less desirable
host for these pathogens
but now you also have an active
responsibility in fighting them off
keeping yourself at a proper body
temperature would become a crucial part
of your everyday life since you'd be
relying on external sources of heat your
house would have to be kept much warmer
than you're used to your thermostat
would not only control the temperature
of your house it would be setting the
exact temperature you want your body to
be too during the winter any money you
would have saved on groceries would be
quickly gobbled up by a sky-high heating
bill cold-blooded land dwellers tend to
do best in temperatures between 21 to 40
degrees Celsius
so to make things easier for ourselves
and to live more active lives we'd all
be best to move closer to the Equator
except that'd be a lot of people to move
to one area of the planet and soon we'd
be running into the usual issues that
come along with large-scale human
migration
it'd be overcrowded our resources would
be running out and who knows how long it
would take before political instability
came into play
so maybe it'd be better if some of us
just moved to another planet altogether
yeah it's a little ambitious but bear
with me because space travel should
actually be much easier for cold-blooded
humans when cold-blooded animals
hibernate over the winter they lower
their body temperatures to that other
surroundings and enter a state called
torpor in this catatonic State their
breathing and heartbeats slow down and
they can survive for long periods on
stored body fat by employing this method
a cold-blooded space crew could survive
much longer than a warm-blooded one
allowing them to travel for months or
even years on minimal resources maybe
out there in space they'd find a Planet
that's perfectly suited for cold-blooded
creatures and maybe there are already
some living there
[Music]
what if all ice in the world acted like
this
[Music]
this isn't just any regular ice
this is hot ice
now what if we replaced all the ice we
currently have in the world with this
new Hot Ice could you eat it
what would happen to our ice caps
and could we live like this please
this is what if and here's what would
happen if ice was hot instead of cold
so what exactly is hot ice
well it's simple
it's made by boiling baking soda vinegar
and a little bit of water
from that you get sodium acetate
it's a white powder that's used in
chemical heating packs
now you can make sculptures and Ice
Crystal formations
although this substance isn't made out
of ice it definitely looks like it
except you probably don't want to touch
it as it's quite hot
so what would happen if Hot Ice was
everywhere
[Music]
with all our ice being hot instead of
freezing cold it would significantly
change a massive part of our world the
Arctic instead of the area being one of
the coldest on Earth it would be a lot
warmer
one of the things you'll notice quickly
will be all the animals migrating to new
locations
because the Arctic is now far too warm
for them
although hot ice won't necessarily burn
your skin right away it would be pretty
uncomfortable for the foxes and polar
bears living in the Arctic
Not only would it be uncomfortable to
touch but it would also make the Arctic
much warmer than before and prolonged
exposure to the hot ice wouldn't be good
either
instead of frostbite thermal Burns would
occur
remember although we call it hot ice
it's far from Frozen water that happens
to be hot
this ice is a collection of chemicals
and should not be played with consumed
and definitely not lived in
so that being the case all these arctic
animals would be moving down to Canada
or wherever else they might be able to
find a home
but it might not be all that bad
our new hot ice caps in the Arctic will
take longer to melt than the current ice
caps we have today
it's no secret that the ice caps are
melting at a rapid rate due to the Earth
heating up if you've seen our previous
video What If all ice melted then you
know what those consequences are and
spoiler alert they're not very good
but with our new hot ice caps
they won't melt until they reach 58
degrees Celsius as opposed to regular
ice that melts at zero degrees Celsius
although they would be radiating their
heat off of each other it's unlikely
that they'd make the entire Arctic a
whopping 58 degrees Celsius
at that temperature it would be nearly
impossible to sustain any kind of life
the Arctic wouldn't get that hot but it
would be much warmer than what the Earth
is used to
and that goes for all the ice
instead of bundling up in the snow we
might be able to get away with wearing
shorts and a t-shirt but what if all
this new Hot Ice did melt
well apart from the issues with flooding
and rising ocean levels
we'd have a lot more to worry about all
this melted hot ice would become part of
our oceans
anything living there would most likely
die considering that we're now
introducing billions of liters of
chemicals into the sea
and what would happen if you
accidentally drank some of this stuff at
first you'd probably be okay
in small doses hot ice isn't enough to
kill you
but if it's all you drag you'd quickly
get sick and then die
and if all our ice happened to be made
out of hot ice
would our oceans be made of melted hot
ice
if that happened our oceans would be
filled with a supersaturated solution
and if somebody happened to have sodium
acetate handy and dumped a massive
amount of it into the ocean
it would slowly crystallize and solidify
this happens due to a chemical reaction
when the saturated solution can't absorb
any more solids in this case it starts
to crystallize turning the liquid into a
solid
but that might be the least of our
worries at this point
after all the Earth would have to be
above 58 degrees Celsius for this to
happen which would make it unlivable for
us humans
we might have to move to Mars if this
ever happened
[Music]
imagine earth covered in thick sheets of
ice and sea levels so low you could walk
to a different continent
this is what our planet would look like
during an ice age
there have been five of them in Earth's
history and they've had a huge impact on
our present world
now try and imagine an Earth where these
ice ages never existed in the first
place
what ecosystems would change
would humans have evolved
and why do ice ages happen
this is what if
and here's what would happen if the Ice
Age never happened
over a century ago milutan malankovic
hypothesized that changes in the Earth's
orbit the angle of its axis and the
direction of its axis are what create
long-term changes to the climate
known as milankovic Cycles they create
the seasons we know well and the ice
ages that we're glad to have skipped
but what if milankovic Cycles didn't
exist
without milankovic Cycles Earth would
look a lot different
there would have been no ice ages none
at all
which means no glaciers to carve out
beautiful Inland Lakes and valleys
it also means Earth's flora and fauna
would have evolved differently
grasses initially popped up on Earth
before the first ice age but they truly
thrived as the Earth became cooler and
drier
grasslands Tundras and Savannahs grew
all over the Earth replacing dense
forests
with no cooling period leading up to the
first Ice Age grasses would not have
spread so easily
there would be less
produce
dry ice is one of the coldest substances
on Earth
this is what it does to a flower
and check out what it does to this
action figure
ouch
now what would happen if you swallowed
dry ice
what would it do to your skin
how much could you eat before it hurts
you
and how would it affect your stomach
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you ate a brick of dry ice
dry ice is a solid form of carbon
dioxide and it's as cold as minus 78
degrees
and sometimes people eat this stuff
it's an ingredient that's occasionally
used in cocktails and ice creams but
it's only safe in tiny doses
so now instead of having it mixed with
other Foods
what would happen if you ate an entire
brick of dry ice
but first how would you get it
well you could just buy it but let's try
making some on our own
dry ice comes from carbon dioxide gas
this gas can be as cold as -56 degrees
but for it to become dry ice it needs to
be even colder
and to do that it needs to be
pressurized and cooled
when it's released from the mold back to
normal atmospheric pressure it forms
liquid carbon dioxide and now that we
have our liquid it's injected into a
block press
which converts the liquid into a solid
okay now we have our dry ice
what happens now
[Music]
well now that you have your brick of dry
ice before you put it in your mouth
you'd first want to touch it
if you were to just poke the dry ice
with your finger it would come back red
with a slight prickling sensation to it
that wasn't so bad
okay so why not try picking it up with
your hands
well because after just a few seconds of
having the dry ice in your hands your
skin cells would start to freeze and
then die
if you kept it in your hands any longer
your skin would begin to turn blue and
gray and eventually you'd lose all
sensation in your hands
and now after learning about how
damaging this can be to your body you're
still curious enough to see what would
happen if you ate this brick of dry ice
are you serious
okay fine
so as soon as you ingested the dry ice
you'd immediately feel the same
sensation you did on your hand but in
your mouth
your tongue and mouth tissue would begin
to sting and feel incredibly numb
and don't forget about your teeth
you know how bad it feels when you chew
ice cream
yeah imagine that but much much worse
your entire mouth would be frozen in a
matter of seconds and the longer you
kept the dry ice in your mouth well it
would only get worse eventually you'd
lose feeling in your mouth forever
but we're not even close to being
finished with the dry ice yet you'd
still need to swallow it as the dry ice
went down your esophagus you'd feel a
little tingling there
and then it would travel down to your
stomach as it's in your stomach the dry
ice would heat up and form gaseous
carbon dioxide
this is because as dry ice heats up it
doesn't become a liquid but rather a gas
hence the name dry ice
and with this gas in your stomach you'd
start to feel bloated and then a sharp
pain
and don't forget about the frostbite on
your stomach lining
luckily you could burp some of this gas
out of you
relieving some of the pressure you'd be
feeling but if you continued to eat dry
ice the pressure from the gas would
continue to build your stomach would
expand and get harder
as the pressure continued your stomach
would rupture
at this point you'd experience severe
pain and vomiting if you didn't get to
the hospital immediately you'd die
oh
so please don't try this at home let's
just keep dry ice to cool party tricks
and something you'd occasionally see in
your ice cream
overnight our planet has gone from a
pale blue dot to a glistening white snow
globe
stretches of Earth have become Frozen
wastelands that are completely
inhospitable and billions of people have
been left unprepared for Life below
freezing
what changes would our planet undergo
what could we do to combat This Global
freezing
and would Humanity be stuck on a giant
irreversible snowball
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Earth froze overnight
Earth has experienced several ice ages
during these periods ice sheets pulse
outward from the poles and then retract
but three of these freezes between
580 and 750 million years ago
had such an extreme effect that the ice
didn't retract for millions of years
these are known as snowball events
temperatures reached minus 50 degrees
Celsius and the ice and snow reflected
light into space as more heat was
reflected rather than absorbed by the
planet the temperature kept dropping
if you could have seen Earth from space
back then it would have looked like a
glistening white ball
eventually the Earth thawed
you know otherwise you wouldn't be here
watching this video but if everything
froze back again overnight
could you survive
okay let's start by looking at what new
kind of planet you'd be stepping onto
ice sheets one kilometer high would
cover the Earth even in the tropics the
ice would be as thick as 10 meters
most of the oceans would be covered in
ice
only near the equator or areas with lots
of geothermal heat could liquid water
still exist near the surface
everything would be frigid it would be
so cold that most of life on Earth
wouldn't be able to survive
especially humans
people living in cold climates would
have warm clothing but this sudden
freeze would be life or death for
billions
imagine living somewhere like Belize
Namibia or parts of Australia where the
temperature never drops below 15 degrees
Celsius
if you lived in those areas you'd be at
risk of death from exposure to the cold
the same would be true in many other
parts of the world
especially for the poor and homeless or
those with inadequate access to housing
all power and energy systems would be
disrupted and with no electricity
billions of people wouldn't have Heating
Industries would grind to a halt even
agriculture or livestock cultivation
would be nearly impossible humans would
need to band together to conserve food
energy and other supplies
you would be ready for living on a giant
snowball if you were a scientist based
on an Arctic research station at
amundsen Scott station in Antarctica the
average temperature is
-182.8 degrees Celsius
scientists near the South Pole live in
shelters built to withstand the cold and
Ice some even have gyms greenhouses a
movie room and a sauna life in a shelter
though would be very confined
you would only go outside for specific
tasks
to venture Outdoors you would need
layers a lot of layers
scientists at these stations where
nearly nine kilograms of clothing
it's them about 10 minutes to get
dressed any Exposed Skin could be
frostbitten in less than five minutes
this deep freeze would also make the
Earth incredibly dry as all
precipitation would turn to snow or ice
that dry air could make you feel dizzy
you would need to constantly thaw snow
for water to drink
and the only way to get around would be
with a snowmobile
or if you're looking for a little
Recreation you could try to master kite
surfing on snow Dunes but be careful in
Earth's lower latitudes there would be
howling winds
this would be another extreme element
making life difficult
researchers still don't know how the
Earth thought from these previous
snowball events unfortunately if we
wanted to reverse the freeze we might
have to change our thinking about
greenhouse gases and global warming
we would need to pump the atmosphere
with carbon dioxide and methane
that means releasing pure gas or burning
even more fossil fuels
on the other hand we could use bombs to
detonate volcanoes around the world
volcanic activity is likely what warmed
the planet in previous freezes
for your next trip out to sea because
the oceans have completely frozen over
what conditions could cause this massive
Oceanic freeze
how would this impact other parts of the
planet
and how could this lead to the mass
extinction of life on Earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if all our oceans froze
Earth has gone through at least five
major ice ages the last peaked about 20
000 years ago and made Earth about five
degrees colder than it is today
but even then you wouldn't have seen a
complete surface freeze of all the
Earth's oceans in this scenario that's
our starting point
a few key factors keep our oceans in a
liquid state except for the coldest
parts of the Arctic and Antarctic
regions if these factors were suddenly
removed there would be ice and lots of
it
the first factor is the high
concentration of salt it lowers the
freezing point of the water from zero
degrees Celsius to minus 2 degrees
Celsius
another reason is that there is so so so
much of it about 71 of earth's surface
is water covered and about 96 and a half
percent of that is salt water
all that volume means an enormous amount
of heat would need to be removed to
reach freezing temperatures
and don't forget the oceans are
constantly in motion too
currents distribute warmer Waters to
colder regions
lastly the Earth's crust is the thinnest
under the oceans
a lot of geothermal heat escapes from
the mantle and up into the water
without those I hope you've got
sunglasses because the Earth would be a
cold but reflective planet
that's because ice and snow have what is
known as a high Albedo that's the term
for how reflective a surface is
this effect explains how polar ice caps
have helped keep Earth's climate
stabilized for millennia
once more than half of the Earth is
covered in ice it would reflect enormous
amounts of sunlight and this would
disrupt the planet's water cycle that
heat from sunlight would no longer
evaporate water
that would mean no more clouds and
without clouds No More Rain but don't
celebrate by trashing your umbrella rain
and snow are vital to all life on Earth
without either the Earth would become as
dry as the South Pole or even parts of
the Sahara
the oceans freezing over would likely
mean mass extinctions of many species of
animals and since the oceans host 80
percent of the planet's biodiversity
this would be devastating
but there are thriving Marine ecosystem
in parts of the Arctic but those evolved
and adapted that way the rest of marine
life would probably perish and all those
dead fish below the icy surface would
have a catastrophic impact on the
economic stability of humans
the ice would cut off Marine Transport
that would eliminate 80 percent of the
global trade by volume
nearly 56 million people working in the
fishing or aquaculture Industries would
suddenly be without jobs
and seafood would no longer be a
reliable staple of any diet
no more Sushi poke bowls or shrimp on
the Bobby
but all of these consequences would seem
pale in comparison to the fact that it
would be a lot harder for you to breathe
yeah oceans account for between 50 to 85
percent of the oxygen present in our
atmosphere this is thanks to all those
tiny Plankton algae and bacteria that
can photosynthesize
if oceans froze these would likely die
too and unless you've planted billions
of trees overnight a lot of land animals
and people would suffocate to death
brain freeze
if you manage to be one of the very few
survivors well eventually oxygen levels
could normalize again but I'm not sure
what life would look like for you on
this frozen planet
from boating to kayaking and whale
watching the ocean gives us joy and
sadly you would no longer experience the
calming effect of looking at the water
you could pick up a fun activity like
kite surfing but with frozen waves
falling would really really hurt
I wonder what's worse the ocean's
freezing or completely evaporating
well that sounds like a topic for
another what if
[Music]